lastly you talked about starting the
script is part of the difficult process
is it you like the middle part or is
finishing actually the the best part
about writing because you feel the sense
of completion you've seen your character
go through these different arcs you feel
like this is a living entity and I think
the best part of writing a script is
when you actually you've actually
written enough of the beginning the
middle and the end that you have
visualized the whole entire puzzle in a
certain way so now you're just along for
the ride and it's not it's not like
painful and hard and trying to figure
anything out you figured it out now it's
just like I'm going to sit down and
write this scene or I'm going to put
that scene I'm going to put this scene
here I'm going to put this in here
because I think of screenwriting like a
puzzle I very rarely write in Chronicle
chronological order I will literally
write a scene that I know is going to be
in the movie I might write the ending I
mean I literally and then I'll start
moving on oh no the scene goes here the
scene goes here know some people do that
with index cards like though right put
put the thing together with index cards
I just do it in the script I just cut
and paste and put that scene there and
I'll like write a scene and they just go
more more MORE knowing that i'm going to
write more scenes there but knowing that
i need to write that seemed so i think
once you have actually i guess it's a
confidence thing once you're confident
that you know the story and the
characters and they're going to you know
it's like hey I can see Vegas we're
going to get there it's right there you
see the lights and everything I'm in
barstow all right everybody is right
that's like the most exciting part
there's a little bittersweet thing it's
great to finish like yes of course you
love to finish but a little bittersweet
thing to finishing it's sort of like
finishing a good book you're like oh my
god so right now what am I gonna do
is there more than mid no it's over it's
done so there's a little bit of
something that you know and I think
people feel that when they read a really
good book yeah and they're just like wow
do I I'm not going to see those
characters again and that was amazing
and but it's done yeah there's like
there's a loneliness there so so when
you began writing did you try to do it
in chronological order and then you
found that there were different times
when you meant to write down a certain
seen you really had a lot of passion for
it and you didn't it affected it later
um I think my first script because I it
came in a certain way I did try and
write it in chronological order but what
was great about it was you know this is
back in the 90s where ensemble you know
pieces were amazing everyone loved them
now it's like oh that's dated that's
crash like seriously I still like those
but the great thing about those is their
kind of vignette e in a way so you got
four or five different stories so you
it's easy to just go from one story to
the next one story to the next that was
actually what was really great about
driving by the door for me as a
first-time writer it might have been
daunting to write a hundred 90 120 pages
if I thought of it like that but I
didn't think of it like that I just
thought of it as these different it was
like eight different stories that I was
working on and if I and I was like the
audience when I got kind of tired or
whatever of writing that story I went to
another story so it organically
rhythmically worked for the audience to
because right when it's time to move to
the next story I would just move to the
next story cuz because I organically did
it anyway it's like okay I'm good with
that for now I'm gonna go to this one
and then come back to it at the right
time when I miss those characters and
then when you were editing then you were
able to tie those a tie them all
together
you